HAPPENS, RIGHT?
>> THANK YOU BOTH.
>> THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
TRIED TO HIDE FROM THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
ONE IS THE MASSIVE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S LACK OF
PREPARATION TO DEAL WITH THIS
MASSIVE NUMBER.
THE SECOND THING THEY WANT TO
HIDE IS THIS, THAT IS THAT WITH
EVERY PERSON COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER, IT EMPOWERS AND IT
ENRICHES THE DRUG CARTELS.
>> Bill: THAT FROM LAST HOUR
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT.
INTERESTING CONVERSATION
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS HERE.
IT IS NOT JUST AN ISSUE IN
TEXAS.
YOU LOOK AT A BIRD’S EYE VIEW
OF A NEW MEXICO CATTLE RANCHERS
PROPERTY WHERE THE UNFINISHED
BORDER WALL LEAVES A MILE LONG
GAPING HOLE AFTER PRESIDENT
BIDEN HALTED CONSTRUCTION ON
THE 20th OF JANUARY ALLOWING
MIGRANTS TO CROSS THE BORDER
INTO THE U.S.
MICHAEL JOHNSON IS THE RANCHER
AND WITH US NOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I’VE HEARD COMMENTS FROM
RANCHERS.
THE GENERAL THEME SEEMS TO BE
THEY’RE AFRAID.
ARE YOU?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, LIVING DOWN
HERE ON THE BORDER YOU CAN’T
LIVE IN FEAR BUT THE WAY
EVERYTHING IS GOING NOWADAYS
WITH THE NEW POLICIES PUT FORTH
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION, IT IS
MAKING THINGS A LOT MORE
DIFFICULT AND A LOT MORE UNSAFE
IN OUR AREA.
>> Dana: DO YOU HAVE MUCH LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE IN YOUR AREA?
IT’S PRETTY RURAL PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> WE’RE VERY RURAL.
OUR SHERIFF’S DEPARTMENT IS
STRETCHED PRETTY THIN.
WHEN IT COMES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE RELY HEAVILY ON
OUR BORDER PATROL.
AND THEIR RESOURCES ARE
STRETCHED PRETTY THIN NOW WITH
THE INFLUX OF ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
CROSSING ESPECIALLY IN THE
SANTA THERESA AREA EAST OF US.
THAT’S ALLOWING THESE CRIMINAL
ELEMENTS IN MEXICO TO EXPLOIT
THIS.
SO FOOT TRAFFIC IN OUR AREA HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE
THEY HALTED BORDER WALL
CONSTRUCTION.
>> Bill: WHAT WAS THE EFFECT OF
THAT WHEN THEY STOPPED BUILDING
THE WALL FOR YOU SPECIFICALLY?
THAT WAS ON YOUR PROPERTY,
RIGHT?
>> CORRECT.
WE HAVE A THREE QUARTER MILE
GAP.
ALONG WITH ANOTHER SMALLER GAP
AND THEY ARE EXPLOITING THIS.
WE DON’T HAVE THE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS COMING THROUGH OUR AREA.
WHAT WE HAVE IS THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT.
A NEIGHBOR TO OUR WEST HAD
BORDER PATROL APPREHEND A GROUP
OF 12 PEOPLE WEARING CAMOUFLAGE
AND SKI MASKS.
THOSE ARE UPSTANDING PEOPLE
COMING HERE LOOKING FOR A JOB.
THIS IS A CRIMINAL ELEMENT THAT
WE’RE DEALING WITH OUT IN THESE
RURAL AREAS.
>> Dana: WE’RE SEEING DRONE
FOOTAGE OF YOUR RANCH WHICH IS
STUNNING AND A BEAUTIFUL PLACE
AND YOU HAVE SO MUCH LOVE FOR
YOUR LANDMENT I’M SURE YOU HAVE
A LOT OF LIVESTOCK THERE AND
WORRY FOR THEM.
HAVE YOU SEEN EVIDENCE OF ANY
SORT OF CARTEL ACTIVITY OR
COYOTE ACTIVITY ESPECIALLY WITH
DRUGS?
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN DRUG
ACTIVITY SPECIFICALLY.
LIKE I SAY, FOOT TRAFFIC HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY.
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILE FROM MY
HOUSE LAST SATURDAY THE BORDER
PATROL PICKED UP TRACKS THE
SIGNS FOR A GROUP OF 50 PLUS
THAT WENT THROUGH THAT GATE AND
OF THAT 50 THEY ONLY CAUGHT 30
OF THEM.
THE 20 OTHER PEOPLE MADE IT
THROUGH AND WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO
THAT WAS OR WHAT THEY WERE
DOING OR WHAT THEY WERE
CARRYING.
>> IT’S THE 19th OF MARCH.
WHAT HAPPENS ON THE 19th OF
APRIL AND THE 19th OF MAY DO
YOU THINK WITH THIS?
>> WELL, THAT’S ONE OF OUR BIG
CONCERNS AS THE WEATHER
IMPROVES AND GETS WARMER, IT
WILL MAKE CROSSING A LOT EASIER
FOR THESE PEOPLE BECAUSE THE
ELEMENTS WON’T BE AS BAD.
SO IT’S GOING TO INCREASE.
WE’RE A FUNNELING POINT.
WE’RE THE FIRST MAJOR GAP
COMING WEST OUT OF EL PASO,
TEXAS, APPROXIMATELY 90 MILES
AWAY.
WE’LL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OF TRAFFIC TO OUR AREA
AND IT WILL AFFECT THE SAFETY
OF MY FAMILY, OUR BUSINESS, THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTY.
PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE THIS ISN’T
JUST A BORDER PROBLEM.
THIS AFFECTS EVERYBODY.
WE’RE JUST THE FIRST ONES THAT
SEE IT.
>> Dana: COULD I ASK YOU IF YOU
HEAR ANYTHING AT ALL FROM YOUR
ELECTED LEADERSHIP IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.?
SENATORS, CONGRESS PEOPLE, OR
EVEN THE NEW SECRETARY OF
INTERIOR?
>> WE’VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
OUR REPRESENTATIVE AND HER
OFFICE HAS BEEN REAL GOOD ABOUT
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS AND
TRYING TO HELP US OUT WITH THIS
MATTER BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
IT’S BEEN SILENT.
EVEN OUR GOVERNOR DOESN’T TAKE
NOTICE OF THIS ISSUE.
THAT’S WHAT IS CONCERNING TO ME.
I HAVE A RED STATE TO MY WEST
AND A RED STATE TO THE EAST
THAT IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN’T TAKE CARE OF THIS
ISSUE, THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT
WILL.
AND THAT’S GOING TO PUSH ALL OF
THEIR TRAFFIC TO NEW MEXICO.